[Musique]
dans cette usine de gannat wagué on
fabrique des moules et des pièces de
plastique
le propriétaire les uhr tubize va
bientôt lancer une deuxième entreprise
pour fabriquer des masques chirurgicaux
et n 95 ça c'est les échantillons qu'on
a fait peur sur nos équipements qui sont
en préparation
si tout va bien l'entrepreneur
autochtone embauchera des dizaines de
personnes et tout le personnel qui vous
envoie ont besoin pour gérer toute
attente on vend à peu près une
soixantaine d'emplois dit merci au cul
si pour recréer des succès comme celui
là que hec montréal annonce la création
de l'école des dirigeants des premières
nations une initiative lancée par manon
jeannotte et ken rock deux diplômés
autochtone de l'établissement c'est un
rêve c'est un rêve de réaliser la
première école des dirigeants les
premières nations les cours seront
donnés dans les nouveaux bâtiments des
hec au centre-ville en ligne et au sein
même des communautés autochtones des
formations intensives de 12 jours donnés
en français et en anglais permettront de
décrocher un certificat en eau la moitié
des formateurs qui viennent des
premières nations les la moitié qui
viennent de hec montréal sspa en
coaching les premiers cours seront
donnés à compter de décembre une
quinzaine de personnes sont inscrites
les élus et les gestionnaires des
conseils de bande seront les premiers
étudiants puis suivront les
entrepreneurs on espère que l'initiative
permettra l'émergence d'un québec inc
autochtone comme les hec l'ont fait avec
les francophones aient une certaine
époque le développement des ressources
naturelles pourrait en être le fer de
lance
la formation qui vont recevoir savoir
aider les gens à mieux être prêt à faire
face à sow est aussi à mieux bénéficier
des retombées parce que des contrôles et
des opportunités d'affaires ça va
excessivement bénéfique parce que
l'éducation
permet une société une civilisation se
développer mais pour réussir les
entrepreneurs autochtones doivent aussi
combattre les préjugés dans les yourtes
tubize a présenté son projet d'affaires
à une agence gouvernementale
il s'est fait répondre ceci est ce que
seriez pas mieux de faire découverte ou
des mocassins c'est ça qui est
traditionnel la réconciliation sera
primordiale pour nouer des alliances et
permettre l'essor de l'entrepreneuriat
autochtone il ce levier bachand
radio-canada ghana ouargaye